viele junge menschen machen sich sorgen
grund dafür ist der klimawandel
naturkatastrophen wie dürren stürme oder
starkregen werden immer häufiger
julia wischnewski engagiert sich deshalb
schon seit jahren bei fridays for future
ich bin aktiv weil die politik nicht
handelt wir stehen hier mit einem
katastrophengebiet und sehen welche
verheerende auswirkungen die klimakrise
hat die auswirkungen musste die
16-jährige am eigenen leib erfahren ihre
familie lebt im rheinland-pfälzischen
ließ nur einen steinwurf von der ahr
entfernt auch sie ist von der
flutkatastrophe betroffen
erst mal weiß ich gar nicht klappen weil
wir hatten ja auch keine anweisungen
dann haben wir uns aber entschieden zu
gehen ja dann sind wir raus durch die
hintertür aber den händen gepackt sind
das wasser gestanden und ja man hat
einfach das gefühl ein wird der boden
unter den füßen weggerissen das einzige
was ihr noch halt gegeben hat weil die
hand vor dir die erinnerungen an die
flut machen julia wütend und fassungslos
ich habe gesehen wie leute eingesperrt
waren von den wassermassen um ihr leben
bangen muss nicht mehr fliegen konnten
und es zeigt zum einen das versagen
thema klimaschutz auf und zum anderen
auch das zu sagen thema hochwasserschutz
und katastrophenschutz solche starkregen
ereignisse sowie zunehmende trockenheit
und hitzeperioden wirken sich auch auf
den wald aus den wichtigsten co2
speicher für jan simon und felix drei
studenten der forstwissenschaft aus
göttingen ist das trauriger alltag
dort in den wäldern wo ich noch als kind
gespielt habe stehen heute keine bäume
mehr und grund ist der klimawandel und
in diesem moment realisiere ich immer
dass das kein spaß ist und dass das kann
der theorie sondern dass es bittere und
ernste realität ist auf ihrem youtube
kanal forst erklärt informieren sie seit
märz 2020 darüber wie katastrophal der
zustand des waldes ist und was an
gesunden bäumen so wichtig ist für das
klima
speicherfunktion und schutzfunktion
wieder wald hier mit dem wasser
übernimmt wald es wasserspeicher und
damit auch ein natürlicher schutz vor
sturzfluten und überschwemmungen wenn er
gesund ist doch dem wald geht es so
schlecht wie nie zuvor nicht nur ganze
fichtenwälder fallen dem borkenkäfer zum
opfer auch die als robust geglaubte
rotbuche ist schon längst betroffen das
ist der so genannte schlein fluss an der
buche das ist eine reaktion des baumes
auf trockenheit der bahn wirklich bluten
und es tut doch so ein bisschen weh das
so zu sehen weil wir halt wissen dass
dieser baum ja keine guten chancen mehr
im klimawandel haben mit der klimawandel
ist eine so existenzielle bedrohung für
die menschheit für jeden von uns und wir
als junge menschen und die generation
die nach uns kommt wird wenn wir nicht
jetzt schleunigst etwas tun definitiv
kein lebenswertes leben haben
julia sieht es ähnlich extrem wetter wie
der starkregen im aartal wird immer
häufiger sie vermisst klare antworten
der politik
wir kriegen nur leere worte zu hören wie
noch eine schippe drauf oder wir
brauchen unbedingt mehr tempo beim
klimaschutz die politiker in hamm unsere
zukunft ja unser leben in ihren händen
und sollten auch endlich mal anfangen
danach zu handeln
[Applaus]
und hier ist sie heute abend bei uns
julia sehr schnell ski toll dass du da
bist schönen guten abend
julia das haus ist im was wir gerade
gesehen haben ist immer noch ja nicht
bewohnbar das heißt du bist jetzt gerade
nicht zu hause oder ja ich bin nicht
sauer okay und wir haben dich jetzt
kennengelernt in dem film als eine junge
frau die ja am eigenen leib erlebt was
passieren kann wenn der regen einfach
nicht mehr aufhört und ganze häuser mit
sich reißt wir haben aber auch eine
junge frau erlebt die eigentlich ja
möchte ich meiner sagen frustriert schon
beinahe ist von der politik was wäre
deine erwartung deine frage an die
politikerinnen und politiker heute abend
ja und vielleicht noch mal auf die frage
von nebenan zu gehen eine welt in 20
jahren in deutschland und 20 jahren habe
ich momentan ein bisschen angst vor
thema klimaschutz weil der weg den wir
gehen keine einzige partei hatten 1,5
grad punkt vor uns ziel und ich frage
mich was soll daraus werden auch eben
fiel der satz wir wollen im einklang mit
der ökologie leben das wünsche ich mir
auch aber es passiert halt nicht und da
stelle ich mir einfach die frage wie
sollen wähler innen und wie soll ich
auch der politik noch vertrauen die ganz
große frage julia vielen dank nach dem
vertrauen ich beginne jetzt vielleicht
mal mit der partei die dieses land auf
bundesebene ist seit 16 jahren regiert
seit 16 jahren an der macht ist herr
sparen was wäre ihre antwort an julia
nun ich werde dafür dass wir miteinander
sehen dass wir auch tatsächlich schon
viel entschieden heimlich krieg öfter in
den diskussionen gesagt das passiert ja
nichts aber in diesem land ist viel
passiert in den letzten jahren bei der
förderung von erneuerbaren energien
gesteigen aus der kohle aussteigen
gleichzeitig aus der kernenergie aus wir
haben miteinander ein ziel vereinbart im
übrigen auch nach nach dem
verfassungsgerichtsurteil sogar im
deutschen bundestag wir wollen auch bis
2045 klimaneutralität was aber eben
genau so wichtig ist und das sage ich
dann auch ganz offen wenn es ein land
sein soll das eben auch wirtschaftlich
starkes dass sich soziale sicherung ein
gutes bildungssystem leisten kann dann
müssen wir die dinge eben auch in eine
gute balance bringen also die frage co2
neutralität ja aber die frage ist wie
ich möchte nicht dass wir dabei
wirtschaftliche stärke arbeitsplätze
verlieren dass wir das durch technologie
schaffen co2 neutral ist werke co2
neutrale chemiewerke und nicht am ende
in deutschland wird dir stahlwerk
abgebaut in china wieder aufgebaut wir
fühlen uns gut fürs klima ist nichts
gewonnen und deswegen geht es eben auch
um einen ausgleich auch bei dieser frage
wie übrigens bei allen politischen
fragen um einen ausgleich natürlich auch
von verschiedenen aspekten das ziel ist
aber klar sie werben für ein ausbrecher
spahn vor gefalle auch an ihre partei
und dann sie ganz persönlich die frage
das mangelnde vertrauen was wir da
gerade gehört haben von einer jungen
bald wählerin das müssen sie sich auch
zu schreiben lassen oder es geht
generell darum dass hier gerade auch mit
der jungen generation stärker ins
gespräch kommen dass wir gemeinsam auch
überlegen beraten was zu tun ist und das
wir aber als politikum klaren plan haben
und es ist unstrittig dass auch die
sozialdemokratie das thema klimawandel
klimafreundliche städte
klimafreundliches klimaneutrales land
als ganz großen schwerpunkt sieht das
ist ein querschnittsthema das wird
deutschland auch nicht alleine
bewältigen können sondern da geht es um
die europäische um die globale
zusammenarbeit aber es geht auch darum
dass wir das mit den menschen machen und
nicht einige sagen ich kann mir das
nicht leisten ich weiß gar nicht was
werden wird ich habe angst meine arbeit
zu verlieren es geht darum dass wir eben
diese balance zwischen den verschiedenen
interessen finden und ganz klar sagen
dieses thema gehört in alle
politikbereiche es muss uns alle
höchstgradig beschäftigen und angehen
und das ist die aufgabe für die
kommenden jahre und die bundesregierung
hat ja dazu beschlüsse gefasst gelder
zur verfügung gestellt das ist ja in die
wege geleitet und da geht es jetzt darum
dass das konsequent auch umgesetzt wird
jetzt ist es eine junge frau die wir
gerade gesehen haben frau göring-eckardt
die ja sehr klima bewegt ist und die
sich sehr viele sorgen macht dann würde
man jetzt zunächst mal annehmen dass wir
vielleicht automatisch wählerinnen der
grünen sein könnte aber wir haben von
julia gerade gehört keine partei hat ein
tragbares konzept auch nicht die grünen
ja in unserem kamen steht ja der 1,5
grad vaters steht das klimaabkommen von
paris ganz klar aber was ich eben nicht
mehr ertragen kann ist das dann immer
von ballons wir müssen das eine und das
andere mich macht es total wütend regt
mich auf was gerade herrschenden und von
gefangenen an unserer gefalle gesagt
haben die verwaltung die ganze zeit die
republik und sorgen nicht dafür
das vereinbar ist wir wissen doch
wirtschaft und klimaschutz das schafft
arbeitsplätze das kostet keine wir
wissen doch die soziale frage und
klimaschutz gehören zusammen wir erleben
gerade leider einen urlaub scholz als
kanzlerkandidaten der immer sagt das
wären widersprüche nein im gegenteil wir
haben auch ihre nachfolgerin die das wir
aber vorschläge dazu gemacht wie das
geht und deswegen ganz klar wir können
uns nicht mehr leisten noch zuzuwarten
wir können uns nicht mehr leisten über
balance zu reden wenn die kipp punkte
schon vor uns sind ich möchte nicht mehr
dass sich julia und felix und andere
noch jüngere kinder angst haben müssen
vor der zukunft ich möchte dass wir
unseren job machen als politikerin und
politik wir möchten das nicht aber sie
kommen wir damit sogar bei julia nicht
an na ja das werden wir sicherlich dann
noch weiter diskutieren ob wir nicht
gemeinsam sagen das wäre auch mein
versprechen mein versprechen ist dass
wir die besten aus all denen die sich
gedanken gemacht haben wie es geht
zusammenholen aus der wissenschaft aus
der wirtschaft die längst bereit sind
dass sie sagen wir kriegen das zusammen
eltern jugendliche die klimabewegung
insgesamt dass wir sagen wir kriegen wir
es gemeinsam hin und damit müssen wir
aber jetzt anfangen nicht mehr reden
nicht mehr überschritten nicht mehr
sagen vielleicht ziele sondern jetzt
anfangen die japanischen einen angriff
mode ganz kurz ich würde gerne ja noch
mal kurz mit reinnehmen hier du hast es
gehört julia ein versprechen ein angebot
ist da jetzt schon was dabei ein
politiker der auf ausgleich bedacht sind
ist etwas dabei was nicht überzeugt
wir müssen uns an dieser stelle nochmal
bewusst machen dass für einer enormen
krisen wir sind wir können uns gar nicht
die frage stellen ob wir wirtschaft und
klimaschutz in
einklang bringen das müssen wir tun
sonst bleibt man sich interessiert und
es geht glaube es gibt einen sozial
gerechten klimaschutz das ist wirklich
und die worte die ihr fallen die sind
schön und wenn das alles in tat
umgesetzt wird dann würde ich mich
freuen 2030 aus der kohle raus aber die
realität sieht ein bisschen anders aus
2020 wurde unter gelb schwarze regierung
in nrw in neuss kohlekraftwerk ans werk
genommen in hessen wurde und grün
schwarzer regierung so werden 45 hektar
wald gerodet für eine neue autobahn und
erst nachdem das verfassungsgericht ist
ein klimagesetz als verfassungswidrig
teilweise verfassungswidrig erklärt hat
noch mal überarbeitet das klingt schön
aber so sagen was passieren es muss auch
was passiert du hast
schwarz-gelb angesprochen bei gelb
christian lindner ihr angebot an
menschen die sich sehr viel sorge ums
klima machen ist es der markt wird schon
alles richten oder haben sie dann noch
an weitergehen das angebot nein der
markt alleine richtet es nicht wir
brauchen ein zentrales ziel ich bin
sogar von einem verbot sprechen nämlich
das verbot zu viel co2 in deutschland
auszustoßen und dann müssen wir unsere
ingenieure und techniker in die lage
versetzen an diesem ziel zu arbeiten
die technologien sind ja vielfach
verfügbar
wasserstoff windparks die vor der küste
entstehen synthetischer kraftstoff im
verbrennungsmotor
dezentrale energieerzeugung die mit
künstlicher intelligenz gesteuert ist da
wo die braunkohle wegfällt da werden
sehen entstehen da können algen
gezüchtet werden die co2 speichern und
natürlich ist es möglich auch in
deutschland wald aufzuforsten als
natürliche co2 senkt also ich bin dafür
dass wir unsere ingenieure und techniker
auf die aufgabe setzen dass wir unser
privates investitionskapital und unser
know-how einsetzen dass wird julia
business geht aber nicht alleine helfen
weil es eine globale aufgabe ist und
hier kommt jetzt unsere besondere
verantwortung als industrie als
technologie nation wir müssen bei uns
zeigen dass wir klimaschutz ein leben in
freiheit und wirtschaftliche
perspektiven verbinden können damit
klimaschutz zu einem exportschlager wird
china indien afrika südamerika können ja
nicht auf wohlstand verzichten weil sie
keinen haben also müssen wir ihnen
zeigen wie ist es möglich ein modell zu
finden freiheit wirtschaftlichen
fortschritt und klimaschutz zu verbinden
und wenn das eine nation kann dann wir
also das setzt einer fiel auf innovation
aber hat auch das wort verbot in den
mund genommen graz 1 einmal am anfang
frau weiter die afd können sie der
richtige adressat für jemand wie julia
die sich sehr viel sorgen macht um bei
den klimawandel ja natürlich
weil wir grundsätzlich sehr gut finden
wenn sich junge leute für ein anliegen
engagieren und wir müssen da aber eine
sachliche diskussion führen und
grundsätzlich die ebenen trennen
grundsätzlich ist es ja so dass der
zusammenhang zwischen klimawandel und
hochwasserkatastrophen nicht
nachgewiesen ist wir hatten immer schon
hochwasser katastrophen und die frage um
solche erschütterten
erschütternden bilder zu vermeiden und
die auch menschenleben gekostet haben
ist ein funktionierender
katastrophenschutz in erster linie die
bundesregierung hatte tage vorher die
warnungen vom deutschen wetterdienst als
auch vom europäischen frühwarnsystem da
müssen wir uns die frage stellen warum
hat das nicht funktioniert warum wurden
die menschen über den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk eben nicht gewarnt
um genau so etwas zu vermeiden
wir sind überhaupt gar keine leugner ich
möchte jetzt gerne zu ende führen und
auch gerne so lange sprechen wie sie
auch ich glaube sogar dass deutschland
den den sonderweg im klimaschutz beenden
sollte wir retten damit überhaupt gar
nichts es muss ein eine eine
internationale anstrengung sein und
dieser sonderweg deutschlands den
niemand
international mit macht den abbau von
hunderttausenden von arbeitsplätzen
durch eine restrukturierung der
energiewirtschaft als auch durch die
mobil automobilindustrie kostet uns
hunderttausende von arbeitsplätzen
für die die automobilindustrie insgesamt
schätzt das ifo institut auf
215.000 die propaganda simuliert nur so
zerbrechen ich möchte kurz auf julian
bereiten denn sie hatten am anfang
gesagt sie wollen julia und all den
anderen die sich große sorgen machen ein
angebot machen und dann haben sie aber
im folgenden anders als praktisch alle
wissenschaftler abgestritten dass es
überhaupt einen zusammenhang gibt
zwischen klimakrise und
menschengemachten tun das passt doch
nicht so richtig zusammen ich habe das
angebot jetzt noch nicht ganz gehört was
sie eigentlich machen wollten das passt
sogar sehr gut zusammen erst mal sind es
nicht alle wissenschaftler wir müssen
wirklich die fakten auf den tisch legen
und einfach mal sachlich darüber
diskutieren es gibt wissenschaftler wie
michael schellenberger der vorher klima
aktivist gewesen ist wie fritz
vahrenholt herr löning
sie was sie haben ja gerade etwas
aufgestellt was einfach nicht stimmt
beziehungsweise ihre meinung nicht teile
es ist einfach nicht so dass alle
wissenschaftler diese meinung teilen und
da müssen wir doch ansetzen und
deutschland schafft den anschluss
technologisch nicht weil wir nicht mehr
in forschungs und entwicklungsleistungen
hinein investieren weil wir diesen
sonderweg einfach gehen wir kriegen das
mit erneuerbaren energien windkraft und
solarenergie werden wir es nicht
hinbekommen weil wir für eine gleichen
energiebedarf den tausendfachen
flächenbedarf brauchen das funktioniert
einfach nicht und die wahrheit muss man
den menschen einfach sagen herr dobrindt
sie haben gehört was vorhin kollege
sparen von der cdu gesagt hat würden sie
jetzt aus bayerischer sicht das noch mal
versuchen zu übertrumpfen oder schließen
sie sich dem an ich will auf jeden fall
mal sagen dass wir brauchen einen
sonderweg wir sind die eine der ältesten
industrienationen der welt und deswegen
habe eine vorbildfunktion wenn es darum
geht aus der fossilen zeit
herauszukommen und deswegen müssen wir
für uns den sonderweg in anspruch nehmen
und das geht natürlich nur mit ja
es geht nur natürlich mit ambition aber
auch akzeptanz und das wollen wir
zusammenbringen ambition heißt wir
müssen da dessen dabei ja schneller zu
werden ein sonderweg ist ja dass wir
eine co2 bepreisung auch im bereich
wärme und mobilität eingeführt haben wo
europa noch nicht so weit ist deswegen
diesen weg konsequent auch weitergehen
da kann man auch beschleunigen und ich
bin auch bereit über das thema kohle und
kohle ausstieg zu reden da gibt es
vereinbarungen ich glaube auch dass wir
an der stelle schneller sein können und
dazu muss man die ambition annehmen und
wissen dass man mit erneuerbaren energie
diesen kohle bereich stelle ersetzen
kann als das bisher der fall ist sagt
die abstandsregelungen in bayern fallen
wo man irgendwie keine kein platz für
windräder in nrw ja auch und in
gatzweiler und so werden keine käufer
mehr abgebaggert das ventil die cdu
jetzt haben wir die steuerung ist
übrigens verfassungswidrig ganz sondern
der beschlüsse hat alle oder anderen
abwägen ich war abhängig davon ist mir
halt 1 schon wichtig dass wir das
tatsächlich und es ist immer leicht über
kohle ausstieg zu reden wenn man klein
cavalera eigenen land hat an der stelle
es geht tatsächlich um menschen die sich
einfach sorgen machen um ihre familien
und doch die um die gtz und deswegen ist
die frage wir steigen doch aus ich finde
wir steigen aus aus der kohle wir haben
eine entscheidung getroffen wie kein
anderes land auf der welt und deswegen
stehe ich alexander dobrindt ja
ausdrücklich zu wir brauchen einen
sonderweg allein schon deswegen weil wir
das einzige land auf der welt sind das
gleichzeitig aus kernenergie und kohle
energie aussteigt und deswegen ja müssen
und wollen und werden wir der welt
zeigen dass mit technologie und zwar
nicht technologie bei der die politik
entscheidet wir sind nicht die besseren
ingenieure sondern wir setzen den rahmen
wir unterstützen wir den finanzen nicht
mehr zurückkommen zu unseren zu unseren
deutschen die uns zu gucken das ist ja
ganz wichtig dass wir da immer schön
dabei bleiben wir haben glaube ich gut
verstanden was da für lagert sich auftun
auch ihre argumente haben wir schon sehr
gut verstand ich würde gerne felix
saalmann noch dazu bringen gerade haben
film gar nicht sie sind vielleicht als
aller erster dran herbig als erster rede
ich zu dem thema hätte ich auch gern was
da bleibt ja noch wir sind noch beim
thema felix ellmann haben wir gerade im
film gesehen forstwissenschaft student
der sagt wichtig ist es dass die leute
einfach mehr erfahren mehr wissen über
den wald um ihn einschätzen zu können er
sah man wenn sie hier hören diese lager
die sich so ein bisschen auf tun manche
die sagen das wird schon durch
innovationen gehen andere die sagen
wichtig ist der ausgleich wir müssen
immer aufpassen dass wir alle mitnehmen
dass wir auch für ausgleich sorgen was
würden sie sagen haben sie den eindruck
die leute sind bereit für veränderungen
auch wenn es sie persönlich etwas kostet
ja also die sache ist einfach mal ganz
schwierig wenn man diese aus der
einsicht betrachtet
so wie wir das sehen und so gewiss jeden
tag sehen so wie wir es unseren ja wie
wir unsere kommilitonen das sehen und
auch die leute in den sozialen medien
die sehen ja was stimmt und das ist ein
ökosystem was für uns lebenswichtig ist
also wir haben es ja gerade gesehen das
hochwasser was da entstanden ist dass es
unter anderem auch dadurch entstanden
dass flächen weise wald abgestorben ist
heißt ja die intakte natur ist einfach
lebensversicherung und es kann nicht
sein dass aufgrund von arbeitsplätzen
aber gesagt da aufgrund in der
autoindustrie fallen arbeitsplätze weg
auf der anderen seite entstehen aber
unendlich viele arbeitsplätze heißt es
ist ganz ganz wichtig das ja wir gucken
dass die natur weiterhin funktioniert
und
ich glaube wir müssen einfach festhalten
und gucken was passiert was richten
keinen schaden an und das wirklich als
existenzielle bedrohung wahrnehmen und
auch ernst nehmen existenzielle
bedrohung die wahr und ernstgenommen
werden muss li versprochen herbert tut
dass die linkspartei und wenn ja mit
welchem angebot er selbstverständlich
dass die linkspartei diejenigen die das
leugnen würden dass wir in einer extrem
schwierigen situation sind die liegen
falsch müssen es ja nicht nur das
hochwasser gewesen dass er das erste mal
bei uns im land das deutlich sichtbar
geworden was bei den waldbränden kanada
an vielen stellen sichtbar worden wir
müssen handeln und das ganz klar
deutschland hat die pariser klimaziele
unterschrieben und wenn wir so
weitermachen wie bisher wie die große
koalition agiert hat werden wir sie
nicht erreichen und deswegen braucht es
wirklich auch kurs nicht nur korrekturen
sondern auch radikale wendung eine
massive investitionsoffensive bei
erneuerbaren energien ist dringend
notwendig das ist nicht wahr dass so
viel mehr die genehmigungsverfahren sind
solange das zum beispiel bei der
windenergie die reserven die wir haben
ich komme aus mecklenburg vorpommern
die sind riesig groß überhaupt in den
küstenländern dazu zählt dann auch der
ausbau und wir müssen endlich an die
strukturen dran wenn wir ausschließlich
beim verbraucher ansetzen werden wir
nicht erfolgreich sein denn sie sagen
akzeptanz des klimawandels alle leute
sehen was passiert aber wir müssen auch
an diejenigen denken die in einer sozial
schwächeren situation sind und deswegen
müssen wir modelle entwickeln die an die
verursacher herangehen und deswegen ist
auch die co2 verpressung allein wie sie
jetzt ist genau nicht die lösung warum
haben wir in deutschland trotz einer
anderen zusage die höchsten strompreise
das verringert die akzeptanz für den
kampf gegen den klimawandel
okay lass mich einmal zwei punkte mich
noch sagen das eine ist
selbstverständlich ist auch die
technologische frage eine zentrale frage
natürlich der verbrenner als gegner
jetzt das ist kompletter band welcher
kraftstoff dort ist und vieles andere
mehr also innovation ist enorm wichtig
und die zweite sache war ja auch in
einem satz das internationale engagement
deutschland muss deutlich verstärkt
werden wenn der ball zu nah oder eine
seinen wald abfackelt dann ist das auch
eine aufgabe die wir haben die europa
hat dort zu agieren okay wir haben
verstanden dass es ein sehr komplexes
aber auch ein ebenso wichtiges thema
manche punkte aber auch bei diesem thema
lassen sich dann doch ganz klar
beantworten nämlich mit ja oder nein das
würde ich jetzt gerne mit ihnen
versuchen sie haben die karten vor sich
ja ist grün nein ist rot es geht jetzt
nicht um ich sag mal
rechtsverbindliche äußerungen oder ein
neues wahlprogramm sondern einfach mal
ein klares statement von inhalten heute
zu fünf fragen die ich habe zwei karten
ja und nein alle bereit alles sehr gut
dann beginnen wir mit der ersten
tempolimit 130 auf autobahnen ja oder
nein
ablehnung und zustimmung bunt gemischt
okay die zweite inlandsflüge ja oder
nein
ja und das ist sich nach einer soll es
weiter inlandsflüge geben ja oder nein
da sehen wir sehr viel jahr und das ist
die linkspartei sich nicht ganz sein
denn sonst machen warum gibt es keinen
grund warum
gibt es keinen inland lagen zwischen
berlin und hamburg weil die bahn besser
ist wenn die bahn unschlagbar es gibt
keine inlandflüge mehr dafür bin ich
natürlich müssen inland spiel geweckt
aber eben darüber sieben überflüssig
wäre tatsächlich eine pause haben wir
verstanden dann bin ich dafür
erwarteten
klimaneutrales fliegen machen wir haben
eure carsten hoch gehalten wir haben
nicht kapiert lassen und weitermachen
oder nicht dass das dritte thema
aber sie müssen mir bitte zu hören weil
sonst wird es ganz schwierig das dritte
thema die horrorszenarien beim
klimawandel sind doch reine panikmache
ja oder nein
ja sagt vor weide und alle anderen sagen
nein kohleausstieg doch noch mal
deutlich vor 20 38 ja oder nein
aha einer hip zwei karten und sonst auch
wieder bunt gemischt und
passiert ja sowieso keiner auf dem
aufgrund der markt wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung werden die kraftwerke nicht
mehr wirtschaft wird zwischen beiden
teilen
letzte frage die fünfte frage
klimapolitik ist nichts für kinder das
sollte man nur den profis überlassen ja
oder nein
da hilft er wieder beide karten der
hellen beide karten aha alle anderen
sagen nein da können alle mitreden was
wir bis jetzt auf jeden fall schon
kapiert haben auch in dieser runde
gerade eben wieder ohne innovation ohne
erfindungsreichtum werden wir auf gar
keinen fall vorankommen und das gilt bei
weitem nicht nur für die klimakrise